This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In a lot of ways, Lincoln Heights, Ohio, sounds just like any other suburb. If you walk around town, you'll hear kids playing outside the local elementary school. You'll hear the highway that takes commuters down to Cincinnati. At the woods on the edge of town, the bird song is delightful. Lincoln Heights is small, less than one square mile with about 3,100 people. Christina Kateruchi is a senior rider at Slate. It's a quiet residential place that seems far from the bustle of the city,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在很多方面，俄亥俄州的林肯高地听起来就像任何其他郊区一样。如果你在镇上四处走走，你会听到孩子们在当地小学校外玩耍的声音。你会听到载着通勤者前往辛辛那提的高速公路的轰鸣声。在小镇边缘的树林里，鸟儿的歌声令人愉悦。林肯高地面积很小，不到一平方英里，人口约为 3,100 人。克里斯蒂娜·卡特鲁奇是《Slate》杂志的高级编辑。这是一个安静的住宅区，似乎远离了城市的喧嚣，
even though it's just 13 miles north of Cincinnati. It's the kind of place where everyone knows everyone. If you live there, it's hard to get anywhere in town without someone stopping you to say hi. There are well-kept single-family homes and low-lying apartment complexes. People gather in their grassy backyards for cookouts and in parking lots for pickup basketball games. The town feels calm and peaceful,
尽管它距离辛辛那提以北仅 13 英里。这是一个每个人都认识所有人的地方。如果你住在那里，你在镇上很难去到任何地方，而不会有人拦住你打招呼。这里有保养良好的单户住宅和低矮的公寓大楼。人们聚集在长满青草的后院举行烧烤，或者在停车场打接头篮球。小镇感觉平静而祥和，
at least until the gunfire starts. Most weekdays it begins in the morning and lasts through the afternoon. Sometimes it goes past sundown and occasionally into the weekends. Once the shooting begins, it comes in rapid fire waves throughout the day. People say it makes it hard to focus or relax, and those who work the night shift say they can't sleep. Residents worry about what the gunfire is doing to their hearing and their stress levels. They're especially concerned about their kids who are listening to gunshots all day long while they're trying to play or study.
至少在枪声响起之前是这样。大多数工作日，枪声从早晨开始一直持续到下午。有时它会持续到日落之后，偶尔还会延续到周末。一旦枪击开始，整天都会迎来一波又一波的速射。人们说这让人难以集中注意力或放松，而上夜班的人则说他们无法入睡。居民们担心枪声对他们的听力和压力水平造成的影响。他们尤其担心他们的孩子们，整天听着枪声，而他们本该在玩耍或学习。
The noise of gunfire isn't from street violence. It all comes from an open air gun range that's owned by the Cincinnati Police Department. This thing is huge, the size of about 22-foot-ball fields. It sits just outside of Lincoln Heights right along the town's northern border, and the cops use it a lot. In 2019, the department reported that officers trained there about 300 days out of the year. The constant nerve-fraighing sound from that gun range has been plaguing Lincoln Heights for the last 75 years. That noise truly was just like bird sharper. It was just like your environment.
枪声并非来自街头暴力。这一切都来自一个露天射击场，该射击场归辛辛那提警察局所有。这个地方非常大，大约有 22 个足球场那么大。它坐落在林肯高地郊外，紧邻该镇的北部边界，警察经常在那里使用它。2019 年，该部门报告称，警员们每年大约有 300 天在那里训练。射击场不断发出的、令人神经紧绷的噪音已经困扰了林肯高地 75 年。那个噪音真的就像鸟儿尖叫一样。它就像你的环境一样。
You just grew up with it. That's Doron Stanniels. He's a town council member in Lincoln Heights. His family goes back five generations to when the town was founded. He went away to college in North Carolina. And one Thanksgiving break, he brought his roommate home to visit. We were just kind of outside, just kind of hanging out. And then he could just constantly hear that boom, boom, boom, boom sound. And we're right in front of my parents house. He just looks at me and said, boom, boom, boom, boom, sound. I was right in front of my parents house.
你就是在这种环境中长大的。说话的是多伦·斯坦尼斯。他是林肯高地的一名镇议会议员。他的家族可以追溯到五代人之前，也就是该镇建立的时候。他曾去北卡罗来纳州上大学。感恩节假期期间，他带室友回家作客。我们当时就在外面，随便闲逛。然后他就能一直听到那种咚、咚、咚、咚的声音。我们当时就在我父母家门前。他看着我说，咚、咚、咚、咚的声音。我当时就在我父母家门前。
He just looked at me, said, D, what is that noise? Like, who's over there shooting? And what's all that going on? You know, it's just the gun range. Like, you know, it's just kind of what we, like, y'all just live around that every day. Like, that's just kind of what y'all just deal with every day. It was the first time Doran said really thought about it.
他只是看着我，说：“D，那是什么声音？就像，谁在那边开枪？这到底是怎么回事？”你知道，这就是射击场。就像，你知道，这就是我们……你们每天都生活在那种环境里。就像，这就是你们每天都要面对的事情。多伦说，这是他第一次真正去思考这个问题。
About how he wasn't even startled by something that was alarming to anyone who didn't live there. That kind of just, you know, was awakening for me. This isn't normal. As if living with the relentless sound of gunfire wasn't bad enough, there are a lot of things that make the situation even worse. This is nonstop, police gunfire,
思考为什么他对这种让任何不住在那里的人感到惊慌的事情甚至都不会感到惊吓。这对我来说简直就是一种觉醒。这并不正常。就好像生活在不绝于耳的枪声中还不够糟糕一样，还有很多事情让情况变得更糟。这是警察不间断的枪击，
bombarding a town were almost all all of the residents are black. And Cincinnati police, the cops who practice there, don't even patrol Lincoln Heights, or any of the other towns around the range. So these are out of towners coming to let off shots and Lincoln Heights back yard. A majority of Lincoln Heights residents live below the poverty line, and they can't help thinking
轰炸着一个几乎所有居民都是黑人的小镇。而辛辛那提的警察，也就是在那里练习的警察，甚至不在林肯高地或射击场周围的任何其他城镇巡逻。所以这些都是外地人，跑来林肯高地的后院放枪。林肯高地的大多数居民生活在贫困线以下，他们不禁在想，
that if their town were wealthier or wider, the city of Cincinnati would never get away with this. When I started reporting on this gun range, I was expecting to get a straightforward story about a particularly disturbing kind of noise pollution. But there's another layer to it, because Lincoln Heights isn't just any suburb. It's the first black self-governed town north of the Mason-Dixon line, founded almost a century ago, with ambitions of becoming a sprawling, self-sufficient community. That vision never fully came to pass, and today, the bullets that echo through town are a daily reminder of how the founders' dreams for Lincoln Heights were obstructed, right from the start. During the Great Migration, Doron Stanniel's great grandfather and his great-great-grandfather joined
如果他们的镇子更富裕或白人更多，辛辛那提市绝对不敢这么做。当我开始报道这个射击场时，我本以为会得到一个关于某种特别令人不安的噪声污染的直接故事。但它还有另一层含义，因为林肯高地不仅仅是普通的郊区。它是梅森-迪克森线以北第一个由黑人自治的城镇，建立于近一个世纪前，怀揣着成为一个庞大、自给自足的社区的雄心。这个愿景从未完全实现，今天，在镇上回荡的子弹声每天都在提醒人们，林肯高地奠基者的梦想从一开始就受到了阻挠。在大迁徙期间，多伦·斯坦尼斯的曾祖父和高祖父加入了
a group of others making their way from rural Georgia up to southern Ohio. A lot of the men first started moving up towards this area in the early 1920s, late 1910s. They were my great-grandmother and my great-great-grandmother. They also kind of came up in my aunt's year after that. The folks that were leaving the South, this first wave of migrants, were individuals who were filled with hope and the possibilities of a better life. Henry Lewis Taylor Jr. is a professor at the University at Buffalo and an expert on the history of Lincoln Heights.
另一群人的行列，他们从佐治亚州农村一路北上来到俄亥俄州南部。许多人在 20 世纪 20 年代初、1910 年代末开始向这个地区迁移。那是我的曾祖母和高祖母。他们后来也在我姑妈的那一年左右来到这里。离开南方的这群人，第一波移民，是充满希望和对更美好生活可能性的憧憬的个人。亨利·刘易斯·泰勒·小是布法罗大学的教授，也是林肯高地历史专家。
They were very high-spirited individuals who believed in hard work and wanted to be in a situation to control their own lives and their own destinies. As one of the Lincoln Heights residents said to me, I came here to live better and to do better. After crossing the Ohio River with separates Northern Kentucky from Cincinnati, the migrants first tried settling in the city, but property was really expensive and racist real estate practices were rampant. So they found a space 13 miles from Cincinnati where they were able to buy some land organized
他们是精神饱满的人，相信努力工作，并希望能够掌控自己的生活和命运。正如林肯高地的一位居民对我说的那样：“我来这里是为了生活得更好，做得更好。”在穿过了将北肯塔基州与辛辛那提隔开的俄亥俄河后，移民们最初试图在城里安顿下来，但房产非常昂贵，种族主义房地产做法猖獗。于是他们在距离辛辛那提 13 英里的地方找到了一片空地，在那里他们能够买下一些土地，组织起来，
and say, hey, let's create our own community. The spot they settled on was north of the city, deep in unincorporated Hamilton County. There was a lot of land there. And since it had no electrical grid and minimal running water, the acreage was cheap. With plans to build a whole new town from scratch, the residents started homesteading in the 1920s. These were people from rural areas, they weren't from the city.
并说：“嘿，让我们创建我们自己的社区吧。”他们定居的地方在城市以北，汉密尔顿县未建制地区的深处。那里有大量的土地。而且由于它没有电网且自来水极少，因此土地很便宜。带着从头开始建造全新城镇的计划，居民们在 20 世纪 20 年代开始在此宅基地定居。这些人来自农村地区，他们不是城里人。
And so they knew how to build systems. They knew how to tap into the waters and build wells. So looking back at what they managed to accomplish with limited resources was quite astounding. Once a critical mass of black people had settled in the area, those homesteaders had a realization. In order to have any real power over their own lives, they needed more than just land. They needed to govern their own space. And they knew, from living under Jim Crow, what it was like to be denied that autonomy. By the late 1930s, plans were underway to open an aircraft manufacturing plant in Hamilton County. Once a rural, no-man's land, that region would soon become an industrial hub.
因此他们知道如何构建系统。他们知道如何利用水源和建造水井。所以回顾他们用有限的资源设法完成的事情，是非常惊人的。一旦一定数量的黑人居民在该地区定居，这些宅基地居民就意识到了一点。为了对自己的生活拥有真正的权力，他们需要的不仅仅是土地。他们需要统治自己的空间。而且他们从在吉姆·克劳法案下生活的经历中知道，被剥夺这种自治权是什么滋味。到 20 世纪 30 年代末，在汉密尔顿县开设一家飞机制造厂的计划正在筹备中。该地区曾经是一个无人问求的乡村地带，不久将成为一个工业中心。
So there was a lot of opportunity where of all Black neighborhoods was going to become an economic powerhouse right in the middle of Hamilton County. It was already set for it. So a group of residents took a county map and drew a set of ambitious boundaries around nearly 10 square miles in Hamilton County. The space encompassed the homes they'd built and lots of land prime for industrial development, plus plenty of room to grow. The map was part of a plan to incorporate all of that space
因此有很多机会，一个全黑人社区将成为汉密尔顿县正中央的经济强国。它已经为此做好了准备。因此，一群居民拿着一张县地图，在汉密尔顿县近 10 平方英里的土地周围画了一组雄心勃勃的边界。这个空间包含了他们建造的房屋以及大量适合工业发展的土地，此外还有充足的成长空间。这张地图是将所有这些空间合并为
into a single town. It would be their town, a place they would control. They named it Lincoln Heights. It was a brilliant strategy. They would have an industrial and an economic base to help support the community. And that taxation would have an industrial and an economic base to help support the community. And that taxation would have allowed them to develop their schools, their roads, and would have created a level of prosperity that would not have existed before.
一个单一城镇计划的一部分。这将是他们的城镇，一个他们将控制的地方。他们将其命名为林肯高地。这是一个绝妙的策略。他们将拥有工业和经济基础来帮助支持社区。而税收将使他们能够发展学校、道路，并创造出以前不存在的繁荣水平。
It was a bold move for an all-black community to lay claim to this much land, especially with white towns nearby. Henry says the founders were excited and full of hope. In 1939 they presented their Lincoln Heights plan to the county for final approval. But the white county leadership and the neighboring suburbs all put up immediate, heavy resistance. They were terrified that an expansive black community would attract people from the so-called slums of Cincinnati out into the suburbs. And the idea of a small group of black people getting a foothold was something nobody wanted to see happen and there was a movement
对于一个全黑人社区来说，宣称拥有如此多的土地是一个大胆的举动，特别是周围还有白人城镇的情况下。亨利说，奠基者们感到兴奋且充满希望。1939 年，他们向县里提交了林肯高地计划以获得最终批准。但白人县领导层和邻近的郊区都进行了即时、强烈的抵抗。他们惊恐地发现，一个庞大的黑人社区会吸引来自所谓辛辛那提贫民窟的人们来到郊区。一小群黑人获得立足点的想法是任何人都不想看到的，并且有一场运动
underway that simply attempted to wipe the town out. Hamilton County officials deliberately slow-walked the Lincoln Heights Plan for seven years. In that time, a lot of other property in the proposal was snapped up by the surrounding towns. Once whites began to understand their ambition, are they waged a relentless campaign designed to keep blacks from acquiring these industrial lands. One critical piece of that land was an open air gun range. It was 30 or so acres owned by a group of war veterans who had a shooting club.
正在进行，试图彻底抹杀这个城镇。汉密尔顿县官员故意将林肯高地的计划拖延了七年。在这期间，提案中的许多其他房产被周边城镇抢购一空。一旦白人开始理解他们的雄心，他们就展开了不懈的运动，旨在阻止黑人获得这些工业土地。其中一块至关重要的土地是一个露天射击场。那是大约 30 英亩的土地，由一群拥有射击俱乐部的退伍军人拥有。
In 1946, the city of Cincinnati bought it as a place for its police to train. At that time, the only other building in the immediate area was a school for the deaf. The local black community had asked for that parcel of land for themselves seven years earlier to develop Lincoln Heights. If they had succeeded, you would probably be here telling a very, very different story. Because they would have also had control over the land where the gun range was located and certainly they would never agree to allow it to be placed there. In 1946, the same year the Cincinnati Police Department took ownership of a firing range. Lincoln Heights was finally approved for incorporation.
1946 年，辛辛那提市买下它作为其警察训练的场所。当时，附近唯一的另一所建筑是一所聋哑学校。当地黑人社区曾在七年前要求将这块土地留给自己，以开发林肯高地。如果他们成功了，你今天可能就会在这里讲一个非常、非常不同的故事。因为他们也将拥有射击场所在土地的控制权，而且他们肯定永远不会同意允许将其放置在那里。1946 年，即辛辛那提警察局接管射击场的同一年，林肯高地终于获得批准并入。
But the Black residents only got a tenth of a land they'd originally set out to govern, less than one square mile, shaped like a teacup. Really, just the original housing settlement, with no aircraft manufacturer or any other big businesses. Yes, it was a victory. They had created the first Black self-governing town north of the Mason-Dixon line. But they didn't have the industrial tax base or the open, developable land.
但黑人居民只得到了他们最初打算管辖的土地的十分之一，面积不到一平方英里，形状像一个茶杯。实际上，只有最初的住宅区，没有飞机制造商或任何其他大企业。是的，这是一场胜利。他们创建了梅森-迪克森线以北第一个黑人自治城镇。但他们没有工业税基，也没有可供开发的开阔土地。
The town would have needed to thrive. And to add insult to injury, because the way the county had divvied up the land, the Cincinnati Police Gun Range was now right on the border of Lincoln Heights. And because Lincoln Heights. And because Lincoln Heights was granted precious little space for expansion, residents would ultimately end up living right next door.
该镇原本需要这些来蓬勃发展。更糟糕的是，由于县里划分土地的方式，辛辛那提警察射击场现在恰好位于林肯高地的边界上。正因为林肯高地。正因为林肯高地只获得了极少的扩张空间，居民们最终只能住在隔壁。
But whatever nuisance the range presented, it wasn't enough to dull the shine of an all-black town on the rise. In the 1950s and 60s, the population of Lincoln Heights ballooned. Small businesses thrived, and the community started its own police force in town council. The aircraft manufacturer became a general electric plan. And although it wasn't in Lincoln Heights, like the founders wanted, residents still got good jobs at GE. This is Wakanda, you asked my grandpa. She said, we did it all.
但无论这个射击场带来什么骚扰，它都不足以掩盖一个蓬勃发展的全黑人城镇的光芒。在 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，林肯高地的人口激增。小企业蓬勃发展，社区在镇议会中成立了自己的警察部队。飞机制造商变成了通用电气工厂。尽管它不在林肯高地，不像奠基者们希望的那样，但居民们仍然在通用电气找到了好工作。这就是瓦坎达，你问我爷爷。她说，我们把这一切都做到了。
I said, I've literally heard, you're naming me, we did it all. I had to say, I've literally heard, you named it, we did it. We had everything here. Daran Stanniel's loves regaling his kids with stories from the town's glory days that he heard from his elders. They would tell him, I'd work a job here, go to the grocery store here. I went to the pharmacy here.
我说，我 literalmente 听过，你点名了，我们把这一切都做到了。我不得不说，我字面意思上听过，你点名了，我们做到了。我们这里应有尽有。多伦·斯坦尼斯很喜欢给他的孩子们讲从长辈那里听来的小镇辉煌时期的故事。他们会告诉他：“我在这里找了份工作，在这里去杂货店。我在这里去了药房。”
My dentist was here. I went to go party here. Everything was here. I went to the pharmacy here. My dentist was here. I went to go party here. Like, you know, everything was here. And you never had to leave it. Everybody looked like you. And everybody knew you. And everybody was essentially family. And some aspect of it. That sounds like paradise. But of course, it wasn't perfect. DeRonce's grandfather, Albert Daniels, has lived in Lincoln Heights since before it was even called Lincoln Heights. Oh, yeah, I was born here in 1927.
“我的牙医在这里。我来这里参加派对。一切都在这里。”我在这里去了药房。我的牙医在这里。我来这里参加派对。就像，你知道，一切都在这里。你永远不必离开它。每个人都长得像你。每个人都认识你。而且从某种意义上说，每个人基本上都是家人。这听起来像天堂。但当然，它并非完美无缺。多伦的祖父阿尔伯特·丹尼尔斯在林肯高地甚至还不叫林肯高地的时候就住在这里了。哦，是的，我 1927 年出生在这里。
Born now, they don't build streets. In the 1970s, Albert got elected to the town council, and he always told Doronts that when he thought back on his tenure, he had one big regret. Oh, the gun range, oh, years ago, when I got elected to council, I couldn't get in the battle council to go wrong with me to start fighting it. I think they were scared. They figured they would lose. A few decades after Lincoln Heights was incorporated, the town fell on hard times. First, manufacturing jobs started disappearing in the 1970s. You have a crack epidemic in the 80s, the crime
出生时，这里甚至不修街道。20 世纪 70 年代，阿尔伯特当选为镇议会议员，他总是告诉多伦，当他回想起自己的任期时，他有一个巨大的遗憾。哦，射击场，哦，多年前，自我当选为议员以来，我无法让镇议会里的任何人与我一起开始与它斗争。我想他们当时很害怕。他们觉得他们会输。在林肯高地成立几十年后，该镇陷入了困境。首先，制造业工作在 20 世纪 70 年代开始消失。80 年代爆发了快克可卡因疫情，犯罪率
building the 90s, and late 90s, early 2000s. It was crazy out here. When Durance was a kid, the community lost a lot of young people to drugs, gun violence, and prison. At the same time, as home values rose in the surrounding towns, inside Lincoln Heights, they tanked. It was no longer the place black Cincinnatians wanted to be. In the year 2000, Cincinnati magazine ran a feature called the best places to live, ranking all the communities in the
在 90 年代以及 90 年代末、2000 年代初不断攀升。这里当时太疯狂了。当多伦还是个孩子的时候，社区里有很多年轻人因毒品、枪支暴力和监狱而丧生。与此同时，随着周边城镇的房价上涨，林肯高地内部的房价却一落千丈。这里不再是辛辛那提黑人想要待的地方。2000 年，辛辛那提杂志刊登了一篇名为“最佳居住地”的专题报道，对大都市区的
metro area. Lincoln Heights came in at number 84, dead last. Today, its population is less than half the size it was in 1960, which means there are a lot of abandoned lots and buildings around town. And as life got harder in Lincoln Heights over the decades, the noise from the gun range was also getting worse. Cincinnati's police force grew by the hundreds in the 60s and 70s, and starting in the 90s, the department ramped up its use of military-grade tactical weapons, just like other police forces around the country. That meant more and more officers spending more hours training with bigger and bigger
所有社区进行了排名。林肯高地排在第 84 位，倒数第一。今天，它的人口不到 1960 年的一半，这意味着镇上有许多废弃的空地和建筑。随着几十年来林肯高地的生活变得更加艰难，射击场的噪音也越来越严重。辛辛那提的警察力量在 60 和 70 年代增加了数百人，从 90 年代开始，该部门像全国其他警察部队一样，加大了对军用级战术武器的使用。这意味着越来越多的警察花更多的时间用更大、更重型的武器进行训练，
weapons, like shotguns, semi-automatic rifles, and sometimes even concussion grenades. Today, Cincinnati police spend a cumulative 50,000 hours a year training at the range. And because Lincoln Heights is so small, it's had little choice, but to build closer and closer to the edge of the range. There are a lot of reasons why Lincoln Heights has struggled over the years. The nerve rattling chaos of constant gunfire is one of them.
如猎枪、半自动步枪，有时甚至是震爆弹。今天，辛辛那提警察每年花在射击场训练的时间累计达到 50,000 小时。由于林肯高地太小，它别无选择，只能越来越靠近射击场的边缘建造房屋。多年来林肯高地挣扎求存的原因有很多。持续不断的枪声带来的神经紧绷的混乱就是其中之一。
The way land use occurs within these metropolitan areas and regions, black space is devalued. Here's historian Henry Lewis Taylor again. And the moment you put a gun range next to a community, you have truly devalued that space because you've created structural noise pollution. My name is Ruby Kinsey-Munfrey. I'm the Mayor for the village of Lincoln Heights. Live long resident, a group in Lincoln Heights born in raise. Ruby told me that several years ago.
在这些大都市区和区域内土地使用发生的方式中，黑人空间被贬值了。这里又是历史学家亨利·刘易斯·泰勒的发言。当你把一个射击场放在一个社区旁边的那一刻，你就真正贬低了那个空间，因为你制造了结构性的噪声污染。我叫鲁比·金西-芒弗雷。我是林肯高地村的村长。我是长期居民，在林肯高地土生土长。鲁比告诉我，几年前，
A developer had a plan to build a series of single-family homes in Lincoln Heights. The properties would have been a big boost to the town's tax base. But once the developer realized how loud the gunfire was, the deal fell through. Even though Ruby loves this town, there's an alternate history she sometimes imagines. When I go to other communities and stuff, I think about what would link a high look like if we didn't have that shooting range and if we would have had that land, what would we be like, what would our population be? The closest the town ever came to realizing this vision was back in 1999.
一个开发商有一个计划，要在林肯高地建造一系列单户住宅。这些房产将大大增加该镇的税基。但一旦开发商意识到枪声有多大，这笔交易就泡汤了。尽管鲁比热爱这个镇，但她有时会想象一段替代历史。当我去了其他社区之类的地方时，我会想，如果我们没有那个射击场，如果我们拥有那片土地，林肯高地会是什么样子？我们会是什么样？我们的人口会是多少？该镇最接近实现这一愿景的一次是在 1999 年。
The mayor of Cincinnati offered to close the range, which sits in a wealthier majority white suburb called Evendale, right next door to Lincoln Heights. Cincinnati would then give some of that land to Lincoln Heights, so the town could zone it for commercial use and generate extra tax revenue. But the Cincinnati Police Department was not okay with that. It had no interest in moving the range. The firearms training commander said the facility was too valuable to give away. And besides he said, the noise couldn't really be that bad in Lincoln Heights. The president of the police union went even further. He said anyone who supported the plan was spitting on the graves of officers who'd been killed in the line of duty. Just talking about what's always been, this is a police safety matter.
辛辛那提市长提出关闭该射击场，该射击场位于一个更富裕、以白人为主的郊区伊文代尔，紧邻林肯高地。然后辛辛那提会将部分土地交给林肯高地，以便该镇可以将其划为商业用途并产生额外的税收收入。但辛辛那提警察局对此并不赞同。它对搬迁射击场毫无兴趣。枪支训练指挥官表示，该设施太宝贵了，不能拱手让人。而且他还说，在林肯高地，噪音其实不可能那么大。警察工会主席则走得更远。他说，任何支持该计划的人都是在向因公殉职的警官的坟墓上吐口水。只是在谈论一直以来存在的事情，这是一个警察安全问题。
That if you try to take this away, you are against police safety, you're against the police. It wasn't a real argument. It was emotional gaslighting to keep a gun rage, to keep it environmental and justice. I just have a black neighborhood. I mean, that's all it was. After all that police pushback, the plan fizzled out. That was almost 25 years ago. After all that police pushback, the plan fizzled out. That was almost 25 years ago. Today, the residents of Lincoln Heights have been hearing that gunfire for nearly eight decades. There are people who have lived their whole lives in this town and never known quiet.
如果你试图拿走这个，你就是反对警察的安全，你就是反对警察。这不是一个真正的论点。这只是一种情感上的精神虐待，目的是维持对枪支的狂热，维持环境与正义。我只是住在一个黑人社区里。我的意思是，事情就是这样。在遭到警察的所有强烈反对后，这个计划不了了之。那是近25年前的事了。在遭到警察的所有强烈反对后，这个计划不了了之。也就是说，那是近25年前的事了。今天，林肯高地的居民听到这种枪声已经近八十年了。有些人在这个城镇度过了一生，却从未享受过平静。
Lincoln Heights predicament is extremely rare. Usually city lawmakers aren't eager to place open air government-owned shooting ranges St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St. St on is an in Lincoln Heights or Cincinnati. It's in a third town, but hardly anyone who lives in that town can hear the gunfire, because their residential areas are way off in another part of the community. So, no one with the power to move the gun range is directly accountable to the people who have to live with the noise, the people of Lincoln Heights. This type of cross-terristicional conflict happens all the time, whether it's between neighbors who share offence or nations that share a border. Pollution, noise, a hideous display of
林肯高地的困境极其罕见。通常，城市议员们并不急于在露天、政府所有的靶场设立在林肯高地或辛辛那提。它在第三个城镇，但几乎没有人住在那个镇上能听到枪声，因为他们的住宅区在社区的另一个地方。因此，没有哪个有权力搬迁靶场的人对那些必须忍受噪音的人——林肯高地的居民——负有直接责任。这种跨区域冲突时刻都在发生，无论是共享栅栏的邻居之间，还是共享边界的国家之间。污染、噪音、骇人听闻的展示
lawn ornaments, if someone is producing it on their own land, they don't always have to listen to you when you ask them to stop. So we're in Marion, it's here so we're literally like another fence line apart from us and the shooting range right now. When I visited Lincoln Heights, Durant took me to one of the corners of town that gets the worst of the gunfire. It's called Mariana Terrace. It's a public housing complex with 76 units, spread across a few low-lying apartment buildings in townhouses. On one side of the development is a playground and I-75, which goes down to Cincinnati.
草坪装饰品，如果有人在自己的土地上制造这些，当你要求他们停止时，他们并不总是听你的。所以我们在马里昂，它就在这里，我们距离现在的靶场实际上只隔着另一道栅栏。当我访问林肯高地时，杜兰带我去了镇上受枪声影响最严重的角落之一。它叫玛丽安娜露台。这是一个拥有76个单位的公共住房综合体，分布在镇上的几个低矮公寓楼和联排别墅中。开发项目的一侧是一个游乐场和75号州际公路，通往辛辛那提。
On another side is a long-chainling fence, the edge of the gun range. So it might be just a little separation from about 50 feet between us and the shooting. separation from about 50 feet between us and the shooting. But once again, the direction that we're seeing. At one end of the gun range, there's a wall that's supposed to dampen the noise, so it won't bother one of the other towns nearby. But for Maryana Terrace, that wall has had the exact opposite effect. The sound is amplified because where their wall is, it projects and echoes those sounds back. So we don't just get the initial boom, we get that and the echo pushing back
另一侧是一道长长的链条网栅栏，即靶场的边缘。所以我们与射击之间可能只有大约50英尺的微小距离。但再次强调，我们所看到的方向。在靶场的一端，有一堵墙，本意是用来减弱噪音，这样就不会打扰附近的另一个城镇。但对玛丽安娜露台来说，这堵墙却产生了完全相反的效果。声音被放大了，因为他们的墙所在的位置，它把那些声音反射并回响了回来。所以我们得到的不仅仅是最初的轰鸣声，还有反弹回来的回声
towards the can heights. You can probably hear the gunfire in the background of that clip. I assure you, in person, it's way louder. And a little scary if you're not used to it. There's been quite a bit of research on the effects of sustained loud noise on the nervous system.
朝向林肯高地。你大概能在那个片段的背景中听到枪声。我向你保证，在现场，声音要大得多。如果你不习惯的话，还会有点可怕。关于持续的巨大噪音对神经系统的影响，已经有很多研究了。
As you might imagine, none of those effects are good. Background noise can impair a kid's cognitive performance, it can cause chronic stress and hypertension. And, of course, it's not great for your ears. Regular exposure to sounds louder than 85 decibels can cause hearing loss over time. An audiologist from the University of Cincinnati went to Lincoln Heights and made a recording of gunfire noise in the neighborhood. It repeatedly spiked to over 100 decibels, louder than a construction site.
正如你所想象的那样，这些影响没有一个是好的。背景噪音会损害孩子的认知能力，会导致慢性压力和高血压。当然，这对你的耳朵也没有好处。经常暴露在85分贝以上的声音中，随着时间的推移会导致听力损失。辛辛那提大学的一位听力学家来到林肯高地，并录下了该社区的枪声。它多次飙升至100分贝以上，比建筑工地还要吵闹。
I can't actually, as an entrepreneur, it's very hard to work from home and try to get anything done like I do multiple different things and this is constantly, you know, all day every day. Alanda Brooks has lived in the complex for eight years with her three kids. Actually a lot of people on this side of the street work uh work nights. How do you get any rest during the day? It's no way to muffle it even inside of your home so it's really bad like to the point where you can be having a conversation with somebody inside of your home with the doors closed and everything and they're like, oh my god, what is that? You tell people,
作为一名创业者，我其实很难在家工作并把事情做好，就像我同时做好几件不同的事情一样，而这不断地，你知道的，整天都在发生。阿兰达·布鲁克斯和她的三个孩子在这个小区已经住了八年了。事实上，这条街这一侧的很多人都上夜班。你白天怎么休息？根本没法减弱声音，即使在你的家里也是如此，所以真的很糟糕，甚至你在自己家里关着门和别人聊天时，他们都会说，哦天哪，那是什么声音？你告诉别人，
it's like I live at the back of a gun range and they're like, wow, that's crazy, traumatizing. Do you ever feel like you don't want to bring people to your house because of that? Oh yeah, no, I don't really have any people. I don't have visitors. When we drove away from the complex, Doron's told me he's not a gun guy, but he's learned a lot about firearms from listening to the range his whole life. He talks about it like it's the weather. There are good days and bad days and none of it is under your control. Yeah, so the days are light days, so you probably maybe have about maybe three or four officers using their hand weapons,
这就像我住在靶场后面一样，他们会觉得，哇，太疯狂了，太受创伤了。你有没有觉得因为这个原因你不想带人来你家？哦，是的，不，我真的没有什么人。我没有访客。当我们开车离开这个小区时，杜兰斯告诉我，他不是一个枪械爱好者，但他一生中听着靶场的枪声，对枪支了解了很多。他谈论它就像谈论天气一样。有好日子也有坏日子，而且这些都不是你能控制的。是的，所以这些是轻松的日子，你可能大概只有三四个警察在使用他们的手枪，
just a nine millimeter, but you can still hear the intensity of the sound. It's just a top-out, pop-up- pop, pop. Those days when you're using the shotgun, weapon days are bad, your automatic rifle days are bad. Like those are just the constant, you know. A lot of people in Lincoln Heights have their own horror stories about the gun range. Some people remember times when there were real shootings in the community and the victims
仅仅是9毫米手枪，但你仍然能听到声音的强度。这只是一种突突、突突、突、突的声音。当你使用猎枪的日子是糟糕的日子，自动步枪的日子是糟糕的日子。这些就是持续不断的日子，你知道的。林肯高地的许多人都有他们自己关于靶场的恐怖故事。有些人还记得社区发生真实枪击事件时，受害者
were hurt, but because everyone who heard the shots just assumed they came from the range, the emergency response was delayed. And then there was the time in 2008, when a stray bullet escaped from the range and broke the windshield of a car parked nearby. Parents in Lincoln Heights worry about possible lead in the soil and water from all those bullets in the ground, and kids in town have a history of busting through the chain-length fence and sneaking onto the range to collect bullet casings as a game. And the gunfire you hear in Lincoln Heights is not just any gunfire.
受伤了，但由于所有听到枪声的人都认为它们来自靶场，应急响应被延迟了。然后是2008年的那次，一颗流弹从靶场飞出，击碎了附近停的一辆汽车的挡风玻璃。林肯高地的父母担心地面上所有那些子弹可能会给土壤和水带来铅污染，镇上的孩子们过去常常冲破链条网栅栏，偷偷溜进靶场收集子弹壳作为游戏。你在林肯高地听到的枪声可不是普通的枪声。
It's police gunfire, which makes the range feel even more intimidating. I don't even know how to put it in words. It's kind of like a traumatizing experience, even through adulthood. Alicia Franklin grew up in Lincoln Heights, and now she's raising her kids there, for Black boys. Conversations with my sons have kind of looked something like, okay, we have the gun range.
那是警察的枪声，这让靶场感觉更加令人畏惧。我甚至不知道该如何用语言表达。这有点像一种创伤性的体验，甚至到了成年期依然如此。艾莉西亚·富兰克林在林肯高地长大，现在她正在那里抚养她的孩子们，四个黑人男孩。与我的儿子的对话有点像，好吧，我们有靶场。
That's the gunfire you're hearing, the reason that the police have the gun range is so that they can practice now when you possibly get into some kind of trouble. There could possibly be a escalated situation and police shoot black men for no reason. Followed up with, well why? Which is typical for a kid and there's no way that you can explain it. And so it's basically like you're saying,
那是你听到的枪声，警察有靶场的目的，是为了让他们现在可以练习，以防你可能陷入某种麻烦。可能会出现局势升级的情况，而警察会无缘无故地向黑人开枪。接着是，为什么？这对于一个小孩来说很典型，而且你根本无法解释。所以这基本上就像你在说，
they're using this range as target practice for you. Like a lot of communities in the US, the Cincinnati area has seen multiple black men killed by police officers over the years. I also have a five year old. Now the five year old is questioning. Like mom, what's that noise? He hears guns and he knows that there are associated with violence.
他们把这个靶场当作对准你们的目标练习。就像美国许多社区一样，多年来，辛辛那提地区目睹了多名黑人男子被警察杀害。我还有一个五岁的孩子。现在这个五岁孩子开始质疑了。就像妈妈，那是什么声音？他听到枪声，并且知道这些与暴力有关。
And it makes me feel helpless because there's not really anything that I can do except move. People like Alicia had grown up hearing the legend of Lincoln Heights, how it was built from scratch by black migrants who'd escaped Jim Crow and sacrificed everything, just to have some real control over their own community. But the gun range has made many of the residents feel powerless. Historian Henry Lewis Taylor says,
这让我感到无能为力，因为除了搬家，我真的什么也做不了。像艾莉西亚这样的人是在林肯高地的传奇故事中长大的，了解它是如何由逃离吉姆·克劳法并牺牲了一切的黑人移民白手起兴的，仅仅是为了对自己的社区有一些真正的控制权。但靶场让许多居民感到无力。历史学家亨利·刘易斯·泰勒说，
that's not just a feeling, to some extent, its reality. The idea of controlling the space that you live is a very, very powerful idea among in the African-American population, but there's a limit to what you can do with that level of control when everything else is outside of your power. And that's what we learn from the experience of Lincoln Heights. Over the course of eight decades, people have tried again and again to move the gun range. DeRonce's grandfather led that fight back in the 1970s. The mayor of Cincinnati tried in the 90s. Every effort failed. And then in 2019, a new movement took off in Lincoln Heights,
这不仅仅是一种感觉，在某种程度上，它是现实。控制你所居住的空间的想法在非裔美国人中是一个非常非常强大的想法，但是当其他一切都不在你的掌控之中时，你这种程度的控制力所能做的事情是有限度的。这就是我们从林肯高地的经历中学到的。在八十年的时间里，人们一次又一次地试图搬走靶场。德朗斯的祖父在上世纪70年代领导了那场斗争。辛辛那提市长在90年代也尝试过。每一次努力都失败了。然后在2019年，林肯高地兴起了一场新的运动，
and the energy behind that effort was unlike anything the town had ever seen before. That is coming up after the break. Lincoln Heights Councilman Doront Stannules and Mayor Ruby Kinsey Mumphrey had both lived with the gun range for their whole lives. By 2019, they were starting to see it as more than a source of traumatizing noise pollution. The firing range, they believed, was an existential threat to the town's survival. The population had been shrinking since the 1970s, because who wants to stay in a place, much less moved to a place that constantly sounds like it's under siege.
这场努力背后的能量是这个城镇以前从未见过的。接下来的节目将为您揭晓。林肯高地议员杜兰特·斯坦纽尔斯和市长鲁比·金西·姆普弗雷一生都与靶场共存。到2019年，他们开始将之视为不仅仅是造成创伤的噪音污染源。他们认为，射击靶场对该镇的生存构成了生存威胁。自20世纪70年代以来，人口一直在萎缩，因为谁会想呆在一个地方，更不用说搬到一个听起来 constamment 像在被围攻的地方了。
It licking hides fails, it's our fault. It's not our grandparents fault anymore, our parents fault anymore, came playing in kids, it's on us now. With that mindset, Durantz put his head down and got to work. In March 2019, on his 30-second birthday, he showed up at an open meeting of the Cincinnati City Council.
如果林肯高地失败了，那是我们的错。不再是我们祖父母的错，不再是我们父母的错，不能再责怪孩子们，现在责任在我们自己。带着这种心态，杜兰特埋头苦干。2019年3月，在他32岁生日那天，他出现在辛辛那提市议会的公开会议上。
And that the constant hearing of bang, bang, bang, throughout the whole community echoing is a problem. Well, I have young kids that can tell you the sound of an automatic rifle, which kind of gun that is before they can do their ABCs. I have kids that have a playground. Durance was asking the Cincinnati Council members to show some empathy.
整个社区不断回响的砰、砰、砰的声音是一个问题。好吧，我有年幼的孩子，他们能在学会ABC之前就告诉你自动步枪的声音是哪种枪。我有带着孩子的游乐场。杜兰特是在请求辛辛那提的议会成员表现出一些同理心。
It's just kind of pleading when I'm like, hey, from one council member to another, do you guys know that you've been down here shooting? A lot of the councilmen even know where they practice at. It's like, wait, we have a gun range and Lincoln Heights? To Durance, this was the crux of the problem. The gun range wasn't affecting any residents of Cincinnati, so no one was complaining about it to Cincinnati lawmakers, so they had no reason to think about it. Later that year, Ruby, the mayor of Lincoln Heights, teamed up with the mayors of the other
这只是一种恳求，就像我说的那样，嘿，从一个议会成员到另一个议会成员，你们知道你们一直在下面射击吗？许多议员甚至知道他们在哪里练习。这就好像是，等等，我们在林肯高地有一个靶场？对杜兰特来说，这就是问题的核心。靶场没有影响辛辛那提的任何居民，所以没有人向辛辛那提的议员抱怨它，因此他们没有理由去考虑它。同年晚些时候，林肯高地市长鲁比与周边其他城市的市长联手
towns around the gun range to send a letter to the Cincinnati mayor asking for relief. They went down to City Hall to make their case to the council, too. But Cincinnati was not ready to budge. The vice mayor of the city said, if the residents of Lincoln Heights wanted the gun range to move, they should be prepared to pay for it themselves. The facility had been there since the 1940s. It was Lincoln Heights that made the decision to keep building next to the range the vice mayor said. Basically, it's your fault, not ours. That argument doesn't hold water. The founders of Lincoln Heights were living in that area long before since then, and they please started shooting there.
靶场周围的城镇给辛辛那提市长写信请求解救。他们也去了市政厅向市议会陈述他们的理由。但辛辛那提并不打算让步。该市副市长表示，如果林肯高地的居民希望靶场搬迁，他们应该准备自己掏钱。这个设施自20世纪40年代就存在了。副市长说，是林肯高地决定继续在靶场旁边建设的。基本上，这是你们的错，不是我们的。这个论点站不住脚。林肯高地的奠基人在那之后很久就已经住在那个区域了，然后警察才开始在那里射击。
And because they only got a tiny fraction of the land they wanted to incorporate, they had no choice but to build right up to the border of the gun range. So Doront's had truth on his side, but he knew that compared to Cincinnati, Lincoln Heights was small. If it wanted to make itself heard, it needed allies in its corner.
而且因为他们只得到了他们想要合并的土地的一小部分，他们别无选择，只能一直建设到靶场边界。所以杜兰特占理，但他知道，与辛辛那提相比，林肯高地很小。如果它想发出自己的声音，它需要盟友的支持。
So when US Senator Sherrod Brown came to the area to talk about healthcare, Durant showed up and raised his hand. I've never been fast for asking a question, especially if you're elected official, you know, I wouldn't be doing my job if I didn't ask the question. Durant asked the Senator, speaking of healthcare,
所以当美国参议员谢罗德·布朗来到该地区谈论医疗保健时，杜兰特出现并举手了。我提问从来不带犹豫的，特别是如果你是民选官员的话，你知道的，如果我不问这个问题，我就没有尽到我的职责。杜兰特问参议员，说到医疗保健，
did you know there's an open air government-owned gun range in your own state that's causing health problems in my town? Senator Brown was shocked. His staff said there might be federal money available to relocate the gun range, especially because federal officers practice there too. He was very aggressive on let's do something about it. By this point, Duranson Ruby had been pressing their case for the better part of a year. They'd spent all this time making appearances at City Hall, educating Cincinnati council members, and recruiting supporters from other towns in the county.
你知道在你们州有一个露天的、政府拥有的靶场正在我的镇上造成健康问题吗？布朗参议员大吃一惊。他的幕僚表示，可能会有联邦资金用于重新安置靶场，特别是考虑到联邦官员也在那里练习。他对“我们做点什么吧”表现得非常积极。到这个时候，杜兰特和鲁比已经推进他们的诉求快一年了。他们把所有这些时间都花在了出席市政厅会议、教育辛辛那提市议会议员以及从该县其他城镇招募支持者上。
And now, they had the backing of the US Senator. The movement seemed like it was finally gaining momentum. Then in March 2020, COVID hit. All the sudden, kids were going to school at their kitchen tables. People were working from home if they could. In Lincoln Heights, that meant no escape from the gunfire. Even if you were used to it before, you really noticed it now. For lifelong residents like Alicia Franklin, a sense of urgency was building.
现在，他们有了美国参议员的支持。这场运动似乎终于获得了动力。然后，在2020年3月，新冠疫情爆发了。突然之间，孩子们在厨房餐桌上上学。人们如果可以的话都在家工作。在林肯高地，这意味着无法逃避枪声。即使你以前已经习惯了，现在你也真的注意到了。对于像艾莉西亚·富兰克林这样的一生居民来说，一种紧迫感正在建立。
Because now you're hearing it all day. You don't get to leave home and then, you know, have a little bit of peace. No, you're hearing it all day into the night. And soon, whenever Lincoln Heights residents turned on the TV, there was one news story and one horrifying video dominating the airwaves. A wave of protests over the death of George Floyd spread from coast to coast on Saturday and spilled over into the morning, at least 25 cities across the USA. Strategically, we felt our best way to honor George Floyd.
因为现在你一整天都能听到它。你没法离开家去享受哪怕一点点安宁。不，你从早到晚都能听到。不久之后，每当林肯高地的居民打开电视，广播里就全是一则新闻和一个令人毛骨悚然的视频。周六，抗议乔治·弗洛伊德之死的浪潮从一个海岸蔓延到另一个海岸，并持续到早晨，波及美国至少25个城市。从策略上讲，我们觉得这是纪念乔治·弗洛伊德的最佳方式。
The best way to honor our residents was to be more aggressive with this situation. On June 10th, 2020, Doron's let a protest right outside the gates of the gun range. A few months later, he brought the fight down to Cincinnati with a rally outside City Hall. The City Council agreed to hold a hearing specifically dedicated to the gun range issue. Good evening everybody and welcome to what on the City Hall side is official. This would be the first time many Lincoln Heights residents had a platform to tell Cincinnati in the official record how its police force had been terrorizing their town by way of the shooting range for nearly three-quarters of a century.
纪念我们居民的最佳方式，就是对这种情况采取更强硬的态度。2020年6月10日，多兰在靶场大门外领导了一场抗议活动。几个月后，他把斗争带到了辛辛那提，在市政厅外举行了一场集会。市议会同意专门就靶场问题举行听证会。大家晚上好，欢迎来到市政厅的官方会议。这将是许多林肯高地居民第一次有机会在官方记录中向辛辛那提讲述，近四分之三个世纪以来，其警察部队如何通过这个射击靶场恐怖化他们的城镇。
One by one people from the community sat in front of the council and told their stories. One of them was Alicia Franklin. She showed the council a video she'd taken of one of her sons. Hey, why do you have your hands over your ears? He's standing outside on their stoop, covering his ears and pointing in the direction of the gun range. I can't hear you. They're gonna shoot. It's gutting.
社区居民一个接其中一个坐在议会前讲述他们的故事。艾莉西亚·富兰克林就是其中之一。她向议会展示了一段她拍摄的关于其中一个儿子的视频。嘿，你为什么用手捂着耳朵？他站在门廊外面，捂着耳朵，指向靶场的方向。我听不见你。他们要开枪了。这太令人心碎了。
He's so young, way too young to make sense of what's happening. But you can see his instincts sounding the alarm, telling him something's wrong. Do you think they're gonna shoot again? Before you wrote, who you all saw on the video, he used to get startled and scared when he heard those gunshots, and that video wasn't long ago Now they don't phase them which is very concerning
他太小了，根本无法理解发生了什么。但你可以看到他的本能在发出警报，告诉他有什么不对劲。你觉得他们还会开枪吗？在你写的、大家在视频里看到的那个男孩之前，他听到枪声时总是会被吓一跳，而那段视频也没过去多久。现在这些声音对他们毫无影响，这非常令人担忧。
Audiology expert Brian Earl also spoke at the hearing he told the council about one time He visited Lincoln Heights to measure the sound levels near the range My eyes widened and my ears started to flutter We have what is called an acoustic reflex. This starts to trigger when our bodies are telling us it's too much. My ears were doing that from a distance but in between me and the range where was the housing development in a playground. So there's the father in Meabun. It's too close. You can hear Brian getting a little choked up in that clip.
听力专家布莱恩·厄尔也在听证会上发了言，他告诉议会他有一次访问林肯高地以测量靶场附近噪音水平的经历。我的眼睛睁大了，耳朵开始颤动。我们有所谓的声学反射。当我们的身体告诉我们刺激过大时，这就会被触发。我的耳朵在一定距离外就开始这样了，但在我和靶场之间，是一个住宅区和一个游乐场。作为父亲，我感同身受。太近了。你可以听到布莱恩在那个片段里声音有点哽咽。
It happened when I interviewed him a couple years ago too. Seeing children in Lincoln Heights not even reacting to the noise that was making his ears twitch, it was almost too much for him to bear. The housing development he visited was Mariana Terrace, the same place I went with Doront. Doront was at the hearing too. He gave his own testimony. The residents of Lincoln Heights had been trying to get rid of the gun range for almost as long as the town had existed. But now, finally, after this hearing, the generations' long gridlock seemed to dissipate.
几年前我采访他时也是这样。看到林肯高地的孩子们甚至对那些让他耳朵抽搐的噪音毫无反应，这几乎让他难以忍受。他参观的住宅区是玛丽安娜露台，也就是我和多兰去过的地方。多兰也出席了听证会。他作了证。林肯高地的居民们为了摆脱这个靶场，几乎付出了与这个城镇存在的时间一样长的努力。但现在，终于在这次听证会之后，长达数代的僵局似乎消散了。
Even the Cincinnati police, which had long refused to relocate the range, now said it was officially open to the idea. The city of Cincinnati began searching for a new place for its police to train and it landed on a location in a less densely populated township just a few miles west of Lincoln Heights. The advantage of the new location is there is actually already an open airfiring range there where the county sheriff's department trains. Now there are plans and the works to expand that facility so Cincinnati police can train there too.
甚至长期拒绝搬迁靶场的辛辛那提警方现在也表示，他们正式对这一想法持开放态度。辛辛那提市开始为其警察寻找一个新的训练地点，最终选定了一个距离林肯高地以西几英里、人口密度较低的镇上的地点。新地点的优势在于那里实际上已经有一个露天射击靶场，县治安官部门就在那里训练。现在有计划扩建该设施，以便辛辛那提警察也可以在那里训练。
It's such a simple solution. Elegan almost. The cops will get a brand new facility and Lincoln Heights will get some peace and closure. It almost makes you wonder why it took so long for Cincinnati to come around. The move will cost about $31.5 million, Cincinnati only agreed to chip in about $4 million. The rest is coming from the state, the federal government, and the county. I ask the Cincinnati police for comment, but I haven't heard back. This past January, the county officially announced the plans for the new range and the expected closure of the old one next to Lincoln Heights.
这是一个如此简单的解决方案。几乎堪称完美。警察将拥有一个崭新的设施，而林肯高地将获得一些平静和闭环。这几乎让人怀疑为什么辛辛那提花了这么长时间才转变态度。这次搬迁将花费约3150万美元，辛辛那提只同意出资约400万美元。其余资金来自州政府、联邦政府和县政府。我向辛辛那提警方征求意见，但没有得到回复。今年1月，该县正式宣布了新靶场的计划，以及林肯高地旁旧靶场的预计关闭时间。
Alicia Franklin saw Durant's post about it on Facebook. I just really could not believe I'm like, is this for real? Like, I mean, I was just elated. I lit up, like this is finally gonna happen. But nobody's planning a victory party just yet. Durantz told me the most excited he's been so far was the day he called me in January to tell me about the county's announcement that the range was getting moved. But after we hung up, later that day, I came home, you know what I heard?
艾莉西亚·富兰克林在脸书上看到了多兰关于此事的帖子。我简直不敢相信，心想，这是真的吗？我的意思是，我当时欣喜若狂。我整个人都亮了，心想这终于要发生了。但现在还庆祝胜利为时过早。多兰告诉我，他迄今为止最兴奋的一天是他在一月份打电话给我，告诉我靶场即将搬迁的县公告的那天。但在我们挂断电话后，那天晚些时候我回到家里，你知道我听到了什么吗？
Still I was shooting. So, you know, you don't get to get too excited because they're gonna consensual remind you that they're still here. When I talked to people in Lincoln Heights, I heard lots of different opinions about the projected closure of the range. Some people think it's definitely going to happen.
枪声依旧在响。所以，你知道的，你不能高兴得太早，因为他们会自然而然地提醒你，他们仍然在这里。当我与林肯高地的居民交谈时，我听到了关于靶场预计关闭的各种不同意见。有些人认为这绝对会发生。
Others think those people are just fooling themselves and they'll believe it when they see it. And a lot of residents think moving the gun range isn't enough. They say Cincinnati owes Lincoln Heights reparations for 70 plus years of pain and suffering. There's also a cynical read on this story. Some Lincoln Heights residents believe Cincinnati
另一些人则认为这些人只是在自我欺骗，眼见为实。许多居民认为仅仅搬迁靶场是不够的。他们说辛辛那提欠林肯高地赔偿，因为这里承受了70多年的痛苦和折磨。对这个故事也有另一种愤世嫉俗的解读。一些林肯高地的居民认为辛辛那提
is moving the range less because of public pressure and more as a sensible business deal. Evendale, the town where the gun range sits, has been itching for years to reclaim that land from Cincinnati. They want to use it for industrial development. Evendale is utilizing and leveraging the efforts that the residents are putting forward to make this happen. But with politics, I think you always try to realize how do you benefit from it? That's just the game that we played. At the end of the day, when is a win? Durant says he's already seen a change in the mentality of some of the residents who helped mobilize against the range. There's a feeling of power
搬迁靶场与其说是出于公众压力，不如说是一笔明智的商业交易。埃文代尔是靶场所在的镇，多年来一直渴望从辛辛那提收回这片土地。他们想将其用于工业开发。埃文代尔正在利用和借力居民们为实现这一目标所做出的努力。但在政治中，我想你总是会去想你如何能从中受益？这只是我们玩的游戏。归根结底，什么时候才算赢？多兰说，他已经看到了一些协助动员反对靶场的居民的心态发生了变化。一种力量感
and possibility now that wasn't there before. Like I want the residents to really realize what they did here, not only what they did here, but what y'all gonna do moving forward with this community, because the community was just an idea 75 years ago, just a bunch of black folks that come together and say, we wanna provide black people jobs. And that was just an idea.
和可能性油然而生，这是以前所没有的。就像我希望居民们真正意识到他们在这里做了什么，不仅是他们在这里做了什么，还有你们将来要如何对待这个社区，因为这个社区在75年前只是一个想法，只是一群黑人聚在一起说，我们要为黑人提供工作。那只是一个想法。
Now we're still standing here. And that is now going to lead to who knows what 75 years from now. And that's the coolest thing about it for real in my perspective. Today, the gun range on the border of Lincoln Heights is still active. It'll take at least a year or two for the new facility to open, knock wood, and the shots will continue until then. But if all goes to plan, the day the Cincinnati police shoot the last bullet at that range, will mark the end of a struggle that has been passed down through Lincoln Heights families
现在我们依然挺立。而这将在75年后带来谁也说不准的未来。从我的角度来看，这才是真正最酷的事情。今天，林肯高地边缘的靶场仍在运作。新设施开放至少需要一两年时间，祈祷一切顺利，在此之前枪声将继续。但如果一切按计划进行，辛辛那提警察在该靶场射出最后一颗子弹的那一天，将标志着代代林肯高地家庭
for generations. The way Mayor Ruby Kinsey Mumfree sees it, that would put them one step closer to realizing the dream the founders had for a touting control of its own destiny. You know, I lost my father last year and I know he wanted that to go. He would be really happy and proud of me that I helped get that gun range moved and so it's going to be like a new story. It's going to be like opening a door to a new day. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, musicara Hirsch, music by Swan Rihau, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Our executive producer is Kathy too. Delaney Hall is our senior editor Kurt Colestata is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroube, Emmett Fitzgerald,
传承了数代的斗争的结束。在鲁比·金西·芒弗里市长看来，这将使他们离实现创始人对一个掌控自己命运的小镇的梦想又近了一步。你知道，我去年失去了父亲，我知道他希望这件事能解决。如果他知道我帮忙把那个靶场搬走了，他一定会为我感到高兴和骄傲，所以这将像是一个新的故事。这将像为新的一天打开一扇门。[♪ 背景音乐播放中...] 音乐由斯旺·里豪创作，事实核查由格雷姆·海沙负责。我们的执行制作人是凯茜·图。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。库尔特·科莱斯塔塔是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁韦、埃mett菲茨杰拉德、
Martin Gonzales, Vivian Le, Jason Dalyone, Loshamadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence, Special thanks this week to Steven Kramer of the greater Cincinnati Police Museum. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California.
马丁·冈萨雷斯、维维安·莱、杰森·达利昂、洛沙马多恩、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99%可见的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本周特别感谢大辛辛那提警察博物馆的史蒂芬·克雷默。99%可见是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在其总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。
You can find us on most of the social media sites, but we should probably all spend a little less time there, but you can find other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pI.org. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在大多数社交媒体网站上找到我们，不过我们大概都应该少花一点时间在那里，但你可以在 99pI.org 上找到其他我喜欢的 Stitcher 节目，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。